parto con il dirvi che il baffo da
tredicenne in pubertà che ho in questo
momento addosso serve soltanto ad
avvalorare quella che è la mia autorità
su questo video e quindi nelle attuali
vesti di fabio ragazzi posso cominciare
parto con il presupposto che non ho mai
risposto nella mia vita ad un video
provocazione e mai lo farò credo se
qualcuno tenterà di trigger armi nel suo
canale scrivendo fa vj compra gli
iscritti o fa vj compra al mercato del
pesce
io non li risponderò mai perché mi
limito a prendere quella fetta di
pubblico che la suddetta persona mi
passa senza dargli nulla in cambio è una
cosa che faccio da sempre quando
qualcuno si metta qualche stronzata su
di me per fare successo e finora questa
cosa a quanto vedo ha funzionato molto
bene però youtube fa cagare mitri ghera
un sacco trigger a ma non in modo brutto
perché se voi guardate il video di
youtube fa cagare che ha fatto ieri
youtube tubo e lui fa vj che imbruttisce
mister flame apparentemente senza motivo
ma perché lorenzo perché lorenzo io non
sapevo che questo fosse uno youtuber
comunque sia non sto imbruttendo nessuno
l'ho semplicemente salutato perché aveva
una maschera bella vuoi fare i soldi su
youtube
fai come anthony tre video al giorno
scherzi fake titoli click day e di
quello che poi è come si fa voler mare
una persona aspetto quindi e video dove
il suddetto mister flames si sentirà
adirato nei miei confronti per averlo
imbruttito ma per me il salutare così
con la testa non significa imbruttire
qualcuno ma significa a salutare però
capisco anche che effettivamente non
avrebbe fatto gli stessi click il video
quindi toutube hai tutto il mio appoggio
la cosa che mi trigger a più di tutto il
video non è assolutamente il video
stesso ma sotto il video il commento da
incorniciare nell'oro e questo l'idea
che fa vj po sembra utile qualcuno è
paragonato
allo stesso livello di minaccia che al
cartello attenti al cane quando
incuriosito dall'avviso scopri che nella
cuccia civile un chihuahua nel avatar
notiamo la sua credo immagine con un
occhio rosso perché sicuramente l'occhio
rosso ti rende un pitbull
in questo caso lui e imbruttito me e
quindi io mi devo sentire attaccato ma
come fa un chihuahua a sentirsi
attaccato da uno scarafaggio tutto sto
casino nel riprendere anche video di
youtube fa cagare era semplicemente per
rispondere a quel pirla lì ma in realtà
non c'era assolutamente niente di strano
anzi nel video e tutto parla del fatto
che nelle che le fiere e vengono poco
sfruttate per il potenziale che hanno il
massimo dell'intrattenimento che nel
caso del romics stato cavato fuori è
stato il mio cantare haters in italia e
se effettivamente io che cantò di tasse
in italia deve essere considerato
l'evento numero uno di tutor romics
effettivamente qualche problema di fondo
riconosco che c'è qui non credo ci sia
assolutamente niente da dire sul resto
del video sono pienamente d'accordo
dobbiamo anche parlare assolutamente di
un argomento che da un pò mitri che era
veramente in modo pesa questo sul serio
di trigger a pesanti se voi andate
sull'app store e si iscrive teppa vj
anzi facciamo facciamolo insieme voglio
vederlo insieme se tu schifa dj sul play
store sull'app store scusate esce fuori
un sacco di roba una tattica super
vincente se ci pensate utilizzare il mio
nome così a caso non curante di
eventuali denunce lucrandoci sopra di
bestia tra l'altro perché c'è un sacco
di pubblicità è hanno fatto queste
quattro applicazioni che vedete qua c'è
per deejay chiama prank fa vj quiz fa
vice tv fringe science io le scarico
tutte e andiamo a vedere
che cosa ha tirato fuori con il mio nome
senza autorizzazione guadagnandoci sopra
sul play store
la più interessante la tengo per per
ultima perché vi giuro fa veramente
morire cioè non ha veramente senso di
esistere quindi andiamo prima su parigi
tv a vedere che cosa che tra l'altro è
aggiornato un po da chiari perché dice
che naufraghi uno è uscito cinque minuti
fasti fight 12 minuti fa non sapevo cosa
non l'ho capita ma ok altri fatti anche
gli aggiornamenti di instagram e di cui
vedere l'ultimo posti lista che non
hanno ancora è giusto che per la gran
funziona bene di youtube fa un po schifo
instagram ok fa vj quiz notti a uno
sfondo d'eccezione ragazzi io faccio
nvidia in confronto con paint seleziona
la modalità infinito va bene pubblicità
ovviamente perché figura di questo
vicina caserma così tua sorella al quale
youtuber fa vj ha scritto sei ingrassato
nei commenti
ma qui si fiat e magari stravedevo per
noi non ho mai questa roba devo fare
assolutamente non posso farlo in questo
vi devo fare devo click day dare un
altro video si può dare tutta strategia
di marketing
ora andiamo su papa vj sounds siamo al
terzultimo vedente di forte che era roba
va a peggiorare ogni volta fa vj suns
tocca piano un sacco gli argomenti
delicati che io tratto sui miei canali
ad esempio che schifo i poveri se io
sarò fare i j
a faccia con casa lo vota antonia vabbè
poi ci chiama frank e allora ragazzi la
ciliegina sulla torta di questo autore
della del suo sviluppo di applicazioni è
la seguente apriamo fa vj chiama frank
cliccando su inizia partirà una finta
chiamata fa vigenza fai finta di parlare
con lui per impressionare i tuoi amici
cosa cazzo appena letto
[Musica]
ciao papi gay sono fa vj sono famiglie e
cognomi troppo ha detto se ne frega ma
sono io vorrei successo io non puoi fare
queste cose
6 grifondoro serpeverde ma cosa c'entra
adesso non è vero vuoi fare un video
commesso un gioco ma non so ancora come
regista non lo ritardo
noi siamo nel 2017 ma lo sviluppatore di
queste applicazioni vive mille anni
avanti almeno la prima volta che l'ho
visto detto no il messia quest'uomo anea
ial fvg chiama prime due chiama frank 3
vabbè non alla vendetta
c'è uno si dovrebbe studiare prima il
dialogo che io faccio durante st
chiamata finta per poi parlare davanti
agli amici e gli amici così avete capito
non c'è neanche più bisogno di un pd ha
il mio numero di telefono caricate sta
roba da teli soldi a lui che non se li
merita ma dategli trovato genio genia
prossima volta faremo anche faringei fa
le interrogazioni al posto vostro voi
quando vi chiamano alla cattedra per
fare l'interrogazione voi voi mettete
l'applicazione fa tutta lei tutto lei
dalle risposte fa era un po che volevo
parlarvi di questo argomento ovvero che
il video vi sia piaciuto che ora so che
cosa video reduce dal momento che mi
piace anche vari social convinto dalla
descrizione spero che nessuno di voi
abbia estradato queste applicazioni né
adesso né prima anche perché
effettivamente non ha un senso di
esistere né come al solito è piaciuto
ragazzi a ciò che molti mi piace anche
con di mestizia
se notate presidi schiette e non ci
vediamo l'anno prossimo vi do la ragazza
li taglio giuro che d'incanto 23 volte
mi fa volare e poi di taglio perché non
si può
[Musica]